[Musica]
giocare della gt ragazzi e benvenuto che
sono video sono famiglie e da oggi
ragazzi siamo su happy room che sta
andando un botto in questo periodo ma
non l'ho ancora mai provato quindi e
fatevi vedere il tuo primo compito
metti una mina in stallo rami l'aqua va
bene che cosa devo smetterla mina 75
dollari una mina su gas 2 michele preso
da amazon
inizia a test va bene fai che da anni
tra pirlo e armi fa i compiti per
ricevere più soldi ma la quando se fai
compiti in anno i soldi c'è previamente
ragazzi sto gioco consiste nel fare più
danni possibili al tizio fai saltare 3d
ne infila un dollaro grazie ai 500 danni
bottino fatte adesso 209 va bene quindi
metto più cose e inoltre possibile
aggiornare le armi vuoi reset
aggiornamenti ma perché non sanno
tradurre gli italiani videogiochi ci
sono le molle addirittura che storia
proviamo a mettere proprio mia idea così
non lo so è cosa con venir fuori periamo
white water for è la pena una donna
quanto male gli sto facendo quest'uomo
colpisce il paese sperimentato con la
molla sulle spine cinque volte perché
non sanno tradurre in italiano
scivola prende un interprete in italiano
regala ai 500 danni fatti guardo deve
continuare staraoke perfetto 551 ed è
tantissimo per l'inizio credo madonna
quanti soldi minchia come monet il globo
lega evo bene mi fai mettere qualcosa
oltre le minacce sono le mine arma
freddi spine
bisognava beh ma che figata vabbè ai
ragazzi ho comprato quattro spine
vediamo che cosa possono tirar fuori
innanzitutto di metter le molle sotto le
spine vai a vedere il casino che succede
mai così porca vacca del disastro
e vabbè titoli hanno messo no che ci si
è fermato no porca eva si è fermato
niente ragalo riprovarci in realtà
ragazzi sto gioco in una sottospecie di
sfogo per le giornate di merda poche
parole perché alla fine giochi a sta
roba e ti sfoghi un pochettino se la
giornata adatta uno schifo non so
ragazzi perché il suo gioco è andato
così tanto ultimamente non lo capisco
però burgo avessi grassi si sa mai ma è
così che si fotte sega vai
ok non potremo abbattere 550 mi chiarita
non lo batterò mai 550 impossibile però
ragazzina non lo so perché ma mi me mi
fa mille da anni devo fare per però ci
siamo a 5 667 700 ragazzi 709 sede 25
dai cazzo ragazzo 909 non ci credo 912
ormai le luci accettata 5 non ci posso
che nuova arma sega a regola ce
l'abbiamo tutti noi maschi a prescindere
1063 culo abnorme perché mi chiedo non
sono anche io come un fatto non va bene
ad es adesso c'è anche la balestra che
figata assurda regala ragazzi questo
gioco è ok
cioè uno sfogo vivente questo gioco ct
si sfoga incredibilmente che cosa sono
incazzato alle sonanti ciò che starò
lavoro nel senso è un misto tra happy
with è la cosa più sadica io abbia mai
visto genova indecente se c'è però non
ho fatto molto perché le palestre non
levano così tanto porca vacca
all'esplosivo secondo me ragazzino deve
mai mancare
ovviamente ovunque a prescindere perché
leva troppo però ragazzi non sono sicuro
di quello che sto vedendo le prove la
lama la non ho capito anche se serve per
ovest higazi ok per adesso ok per adesso
super ok quando arriverò ad avere un
miliardo di lame che è veramente il
confronto la gillette può accompagnare
solo fare un bordello rita 800 814 dai
dai molti la juve lo è però non un modo
orca vacca e non ha modo di andare a
sinistra va a fan culo marca vacca 500
ragazzi serve lo batte il record così
sono tutte min e meno male che io non
sto mai zitto porca di una eva perfetto
800 900 1035 record per ad essere cosa
laga 1100 1200 eva bel casino
dall'epoca tocca tocca caracal ai 2200
32 tantissimo per adesso raga è
tantissimo che cosa vuol dire in
italiano qui 15 frecce di sperimentato
scusa frank schleck saxo migliorare
persona mentre la potenza delle mine tra
che storica permette di installare le
mine sul soffitto è la madonna molla
esplode appena finisce nella regia
ficcata vai così dovrei aver lamentato
il danno di poter madonna che bordello
adesso 9 24 1100 noti ok porca vacca
schifosa se sì casa se si incastrava in
mezzo all'inizio ride voce faccia ridere
ma la senso 600 si sa che aggiungere le
spine a questo livello guarda questo set
che ho fatto mica sarebbe la
devastazione totale raga millecento
stavolta l'ho beccato giusto raga ho
messo le cose giuste
esplode slot esplode in teoria le stesse
si scaricano esplodo non si cose tipo
adesso perfetto
madonna teleporto cosa mi porti zio 77
1500 vabbè vabbè mille sette record
della vita 1800 e 66 ravera madonna mia
incredibile sta roba vi giuro a porta al
proprio fighissimo ma fa del danno
almeno cosa non ho capito se fa del
danno o meno però ok bye bye proprio
niente legami saghe sotto teletrasporto
mi sa che devo mettere le leve c'è il
trampolini coli che sparano dritti se
non entrerà mai e molto in piedi come mi
che hai fatto a morire i piedi zio mi
spieghi teoria con la molla dritta
dovrei in teoria perfetto non anti
bloccare un trilocale zio sparano
sparano spa lo sbaglio
taci tu a 1.321 ragazze record non mi
ricordo quale i ragazzi ma proprio c'è
scritto se clicco record 1861 effetto
ragazzi io questo tizio comunque lo
immagino come se fosse un hayter c'è
later di turno che viene sballottato da
una parte all'altra come è di bloccare
adesso 1400 che ho fatto a fare 1800
prima è possibile troppo ma x 2m alla
mente la velocità non avevo visto ma che
figata dai vecchio record
no si no 1871 fatto record per 11 punti
ho fatto record non ci credo mai sono
ragazzi le seghe sono efficaci quando
sono tante non pensate male con questa
frase perché una sola che tipo quando me
non fa tantissimo prima di concludere
ragazzi devo necessariamente arrivare a
2000 ce la possiamo fare la gamma lo
sento prima di concludere 15 6 giorni di
danni da seghe fratte guardati un po di
roba di mia khalifa che si apostrofa
pure di sasha grey barca vacca schifosa
dai da maledetta 1800 eventi dai perché
sentire che fa tipo il rumore della foca
ma non lo so sognato io
vai così che vogliono 2000 e 2000 ma che
ne saranno i duemila 1500 non ci
arriverò mai ragazzo già io che non ci
arriverò mai possibile far 2000 porco
demonio
maghetto e io ho speso un'ora e mezzo
che possa dare una volta all'altra passa
mentre tutte palestre ma [ __ ]
ma veramente passato e allora scusa che
cosa mica lo mettevo ovunque piazzavo le
cose io a cosa minchia serviva scusami
se va beh a saperlo che era così facile
2.857 gli era una ruck e la facciamo
saltare la parte alla tasto cristiano
per quale [ __ ] motivo va bene anzi
direi che ci siamo abbiamo raggiunto un
nuovo record
bastava mettere le balestre non capisco
il perchè è pero va bene non so se
volete un altro episodio distano va a me
piace personalmente mi piace un box è
l'emozione delle balestre quello che
video vi sia piaciuto cosa sente
rivolgere una novità però mi piace
lasciatemi dei consigli ma sotto visto
che se volete che faccia altri episodi
sono cosa mi chiami lasciato a fare
qualche nome ragazzi come se invece sono
momento mi piace anche vari comuni
se non siete ancora iscritti e creativi
ci vediamo al prossimo video da ragazzi
[Musica]